hier soir sur bfm tv un débat est
organisé en prime et en direct jusqu'à
zéro heure 25 1,1 million de
téléspectateurs un gros gros gros carton
pour bfm télé ce soir est un spécial
intitulé gilet jaune sortir de la crise
pour un petit bois un petit message à
vous faire passer dans un instant
s'était présentée par ruth elkrief et
notre ami bruce toussaint ce débat
cartonné bfm a terminé donc 5ème chaîne
nationale hier au classement il y avait
françois de rugy donc le ministre de la
transition écologique et marlène
schiappa donc la secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et de la lutte contre les
discriminations c'était la première fois
que des besoins des membres du
gouvernement se retrouver face au gilet
jaune
on va revenir en vidéo sur le débat
diffusé hier soir il ya une phrase voilà
qui a fait énormément buzz et c'est les
propos d'eric drouet qui a appelé hier à
entrer dans l'elysée samedi prochain je
vais vous demander votre avis à loudes
vous allez donner votre avis et je vous
donner quelques infos là dessus regardez
hier soir bfmtv organiser un grand débat
intitulé gilet jaune sortir de la crise
bonsoir à tous et un bon sens me
retrouver avec pour la première fois en
plateau de membres du gouvernement
françois d'origine et la secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'égalité entre les
femmes et des hommes marlène schiappa
face à eux plusieurs gilet jaune dont
eric drew et routier et initiateur du
mouvement venus débattre autour de la
question et reed ou et bonsoir vous êtes
un des initiateurs de ce mouvement des
gilets jaunes et le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que les propos du militant
des gilets jaunes n'ont pas manqué de
faire réagir il a notamment déclaré
qu'il fallait se rendre à l'elysée pour
se faire écouter des propos très
explicites qui ont surpris les deux
représentants du gouvernement présents
sur le plateau et une soirée qui haïssez
bfm au plus haut des audiences avec 1,1
million de téléspectateurs présents
devant leur poste alors les propos
d'eric drouet sont ils dangereux alors
les propos d'eric drouet
tout le monde en a parlé aujourd'hui
j'avoue avoir votre avis en tant que
citoyen vous autour de la table chez moi
à voir la vie aussi des téléspectateurs
et je vais vous dire j'ai eu beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'appels aujourd'hui
pour me dire ce qui va se passer samedi
et je vous en parlais dans un instant
parce que j'ai envie de faire passer un
message et faire passer un message à
tous les gilet jaune est également aux
citoyens parce que c'est sur les mêmes
bien sûr et comme je le dis à chaque
fois on est un petit peu tous gilet
jaune aujourd'hui et on a tous envie
voit la xai dans le bon sens alors la
séquence qui a fait le plus de buzz est
donc ce sont les propos d'eric doué que
j'avais reçu sur le plateau de balances
ton poste au départ vraiment de tout
mouvement des gilet jaune et c'est vrai
rick a eu des propos qui ont choqué
quelques téléspectateurs hier mais
beaucoup de téléspectateurs regardent
ils très précisément que il faudrait
vraiment que samedi on soit tous unis
jusqu'au bout et qu'on avance en
direction de l'elysée
ça ressemble à quoi ça ressemble à un
putsch vous voulez faire
non mais tous les amis veulent aller là
où il est le symbole de ce gouvernement
vous arrivez devant l'elysée vous faites
quoi me rentrer dedans vous rentrez
dedans mais les choses soient claires
les gens c'est bien pour ça qu'il y a
des forces de l'ordre devant pour vous
empêcher de la gare pourquoi quelques
vous y faites ces symboles république
gens veulent y aller c'est tout mais
sans exécuter ce sera la seule solution
c'est alors voilà ça a été une des
séquences au plus fort de vous montrer
deux autres séquences qui ont été très
très forte
hier et c'est vrai que voilà moi j'ai
envie de savoir qu'est ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous pensez que les propos
d'eric drouet sont dangereux parce que
ce qui ce qui défend tous les français
me dise moi je défends voilà je suis un
petit peu d'accord avec eric drew et sur
ce qu'ils défendent mais la méthode
c'est les méthodes elles sont elles sont
un peu trop voilà c'est ça va trop loin
oui mais mes séries c'est clair la
majorité des français défend des causes
des gilets des gilet jaune
on comprend la colère ou comprend
l'exaspération on comprendre le
ras-le-bol le matraquage mais en
revanche moi en tant que citoyenne je
suis pas pour qu'on vandalisent je ne
suis pas pour mon rôle je ne suis pas
pour qu'on casse je ne suis pas enfin
pour le sorte d'anarchie cahute où vous
avez peur de ce qui va se passer seul
oui j'ai peur et puis surtout moi je
suis pas en tant que citoyenne je suis
pas pour l'insurrection je suis pas pour
le putsch je suis pas pour la révolution
donc je pense qu'on peut être à la fois
pour les gilet jaune et pour leur cause
et les défend mais stop à la violence on
peut pas enfin moi je trouve que ce qui
fait ces hors-la-loi en falloir je
demande aux téléspectateurs est ce que
vous pensez que les propos d'eric besson
sont dangereux
voilà gilles verdez stop à la violence
bien sûr mais moi je suis pas choqué par
ses propos
vraiment c'est que cheminant je suis pas
choqué parce que quand vous n'êtes pas
écoutés depuis le début moi j'essaie de
comprendre le mouvement des jeunes de
parler n'est pas démago s'il vous plaît
je suis pas des matchs depuis le début
je suis sur cette ligne quand vous
n'êtes pas entendu quand vous n'êtes pas
écouté y dit il faut aller à l'elysée
pour être écouté
c'est la dernière limite qu'il vous
semble possible d'atteindre alors oui
mais
j'ai compris en cas oui mais alors
jamais airs il vous savez que j'ai
défendu des jo depuis j'étais le premier
à défendre le mouvement des bruits et
gilet jaune vous le savez absolue j'ai
été le premier à les recevoir sur un
plateau de télé j'ai été le premier je
suis vraiment à chaque fois à leurs
côtés il est vraiment voilà je suis à
leurs côtés à fou parce que j'ai envie
voit la xai me pour e.on en train de
travailler même sur plein de choses pour
essayer que ça aille mieux même pour
pour plein de gens et c'est vrai que là
là là ça peut faire un petit os peur
c'est si je vous le dis là est ce que
c'est pas une attaque à la démocratie
c'est la petite question sur tours alors
non mais voilà c'est tout après midi à
fermer si le chef de l'état veut les
recevoir avec plaisir moi moi je vous
dis moi je pense qu'il doit lire so i
doit les recevoir
c'est l'occasion non arrête eric drouhin
ou bien quel que soit le téléspectateur
il vient il a le droit à la limite de
dire ce qu'il veut en revanche le
journaliste c'est son rôle de l'arrêter
et de le dire exactement quand vous avez
dit lors du premier débat vous appelez
des macros démission non on va pas
jusque là
ça c'est le rôle du journaliste le rôle
d'homme non de la télévision je termine
heureux de la telenovela dessus de
l'antenne ça c'est obligatoire c'est la
convention qui lie la chaîne ossès
maîtrise de l'antenne ne pas inciter un
comportement incivique le rôle d'un
journaliste encore plus un journaliste
qu'un animateur c'est d'arrêter et de ne
pas inciter un comportement incivique on
l'oubli aujourd'hui eric doux et je ne
lui en veux pas il peut dire ce qu'il
veut mais on doit l'arrêter projet je
leur dirai que j'ai reçu deux fois c'est
un garçon qui voilà qu'avec qui s'est
très bien passé sur le plateau mais là
je vous dis même gilles vos propos il
faut pas de faire un faux pas faire
appel à la violence y est pour quelque
chose la caution mais oui ça va pas la
violence mais aussi bien vous pouvez pas
me faire lapider l'on sache s'il est
difficile alors c'est pour les
journalistes à dire dire qu il faut
aller à l'elysée chercher le chef de
l'état c'est pas possible
enfin je vous dis non moi je pense que
le chef de l'état doit maintenant
discuter avec eux après moi j'ai pas mon
avis à donner mais et ils ont tous envie
discuter mais vous savez que samedi il
ya beaucoup de joie et beaucoup de
familles sont dans l'angoissé il ya
plein de commerçants qui sont en train
de faire
leur boutique et qui vont faire un mois
de décembre car excécrable alors que
c'est le mois le plus important pour eux
et que c'est souvent au mois de décembre
qui sauvent leur année après on est tous
avec les gilets jaunes on a tous envie
que tout le monde soit heureux et que
tout le monde puisse finir ses fins de
mois
mais il faut penser aussi aux
commerçants faut penser aux familles qui
doivent sortir qui vont sortir avec
leurs enfants aux personnes âgées qui
font qu'ils sont dans le mouvement et
qui ont peur d'y aller parce qu'ils
disent on va avec il va y avoir des
casseurs et on sait qu'aujourd'hui c'est
la quatrième semaine tout le monde a
peur de ce samedi
le samedi la lame l'a vraiment est le
mot d'ordre c'est stop
oui à la violence bible dit oui michael
et plus grave encore ce que dit ce
monsieur est ce que tu cautionnes gillet
vraiment jeudi qu'elle ne ment pas
m'énerver
c'est très grave parce que rentrer dans
l'elysée tu te doutes bien qu aura
beaucoup de policiers qui vont se
défendre en cour au connecteur aussi
donc ça va être un carnage j'ai fait un
appel à voir du sang sur les mains sera
désormais sur les écoutes ne l'a décidé
dans les rangs de scada ton est juste
nature grande écoute si ce que vous
vivrez des morceaux d'abaisser la djihad
et gilet jaune
imaginons voilà il forcé disais il ya
des gilet jaune qui rentre dans l'elysée
et s'il ya des snipers il faut la
laisser rentrer là vous êtes fou dont on
parle mais il ya le monde écoute s'il ya
des morts la violence au début vous me
laissez pas parler s'il est aussi animé
sert alors pourquoi mais lui il est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement sens c'est
pourquoi dit-il ça parce que ce qui est
parce qu à une exaspération réagit bien
sûr qu une exaspération mais il est il
est porte-parole sait très bien que les
mots ont un sens tu me l'a pas dit a
balisé demandé une entrevue réalisée
et qu'est ce que vous faites regardez
j'aimerais avoir l'avis vraiment
là-dessus si l'appel au putsch et
maintenant vous déformez les trucs
c'est très dur ce qu'il a dit là éric
drouin parce qu'en plus je sais j et toi
tu es comme moi raymond sur ce dossier
là fuient gilles hassaballah wind est un
gars font avec quelques faux-pas faut
déjà remettre tous milieux vous croyez
vraiment que macro et greta les et
samedi il n'y sera pas donc déjà
premièrement je pense qu'il sera à vous
donner
il dit qu'il faut aller à l'elysée est
ce que lui il sera en première ligne et
des gens qui seront qu'auront les ordres
ne pas rentrer à l'elysée
ces îles sont là pour faire rayonner
leur a peut être raison mais il faut pas
dire aux gens c'est les instits et oui
oui oui vous aurez bien sûr les mains m
l'attention de fanny grosjean
mais si j'y vais attendre il faut
abattre des arbres mathieu aller à
l'elysée les 10 et 16 degrés faut pas
dire ça aux gens parce que si on donne
les ordres quand vous anime en pas jusqu
au sniper parce que je pense qu'ils vont
les mares et avant mais moi j'aimerais
bien comme on l écoute beaucoup qu'il
est sur tous les plateaux
j'aimerais bien qui dit j'aime j'ai
déconné je me suis enflammé avec bruce
toussaint neveu je m'excuse on va parler
disait notre rôle c'est d'appeler à la
paix super dangereux parce qu'il va
envoyer des pauvres gens charmants faut
pas faire ça tu es fou là et tu as
raison tu parles de la maîtrise de
l'antenne mais la maîtrise du mouvement
est largement aussi important alors moi
content maintenant je pense que emmanuel
macron sera à l'elysée au fur et je
pense aussi qu'il est capable d'aller en
première ligne mais de toute façon les
salariés qui n'en arrêter de dire des
bêtises mais rien qui sera là
éventuellement des poêles à la pause
c'est pas bien d'aller à l'elysée nous
médias ont un rôle capital dans cette
voie histoire vous avez lancé le premier
débat ensuite lci
ensuite france 2 ensuite bfm tv a fait
son premier débat hier soir l'autre jour
j'ai vu sur tous les médias
c'était bon samedi dernier des députés
qui disait nous on vient à l'eau sur les
champs-elysées samedi c'était samedi
dernier et les journalistes sur toutes
les chaînes ont dit m comment ça vous
êtes député élu de la république et vous
allez là où c'est interdit
finalement grâce aux journalistes aucun
député n'a été à l'elysée donc ça c'est
le rôle des médias d'avoir un eric drew
et sur le plateau mais de les dire
attention là vous allez trop loin
d'avoir un député sur le plateau qui va
invectivé et qu'il à dire attention là
vous allez trop loin
oui on comprend oui on donne la parole
dont doit maîtriser l'antenne on n'est
pas sur les réseaux sociaux
alors pourquoi alors on va les pas des
journées
j'ai une autre séquence s'agit du clash
entre ruth elkrief et l'ancien
syndicaliste xavier mathieu il n'a pas
apprécié que ruth elkrief le qualifie de
comédiens regarde nous les verriers
maculant voit bien que vous êtes
comédiens aujourd'hui nicolas béraud
quel rapport
mam est ce que vous avez vous de moi
gestion et vous avez vous fait passer
beaucoup d'éloquence et beaucoup de
talent que vous ne prendrez pas d'eau
vous avez fait pendant pendant deux
heures avec les gens qui est en face
good way sans arrêt le mépris de classe
il a été de deux côtés des ministres et
du vôtre en même temps je n'ai aucun
mépris de classe pour personne et je ne
pense pas si ceux qui sont ici en me
disant vous êtes on voit vous êtes
comédiens ça veut dire quoi cette fois
ci jamais dry est prise à bhl vous êtes
maîtrisant tôt que non voilà alors il
paraît que d'ailleurs que xavier mathieu
serait pressenti pour être le porte
parole des gilet jaune à points en tout
cas pas la voir enfin ce qu'est doriot
rihaoui ménard mois on entend beaucoup
de gens parler dans la rue avec jour une
phrase bien sensé bien construit à la
télé j'ai apprécié il envoie les plus
grand guignol non non en train qui dit
qu'il est journaliste rang complétant et
un autre qui dit qu'ils mettraient dans
l'elysée mais arrêtez moi arrêtez
norbert ça que les gens et non pas deux
mais tu devrais écouter la radio vous
verrez les témoignages des gens la vie
aux calculs alors à paris on voit pas de
politique ce matin j'écoutais je porte
pas eu tout mon coeur mais j'écoutais
lors invoquer donc deux à droite sur
europe 1 est la seule phrase que j'ai
retenu de ce qu'il est dit qu'ils
étaient quand même sens et qui était
attention des journalistes ont un rôle
parce que forcément les chaînes veulent
faire de l'audience veux le faire du
buzz ont tendance à mettre du buzz sur
du buzz aller chercher la petite phrase
ils ont vu quant à mon avis quelque
chose qui est très intéressant aussi
pardon pour l'audience travail du coup
il met des couches sur des barges ou non
le fait tous les soirs oui mais parce qu
on a été les premiers à le faire et que
on est obligé de fans et les
journalistes ont un rôle à l'euro la
frénésie médiatique oui mais nous va pas
renoncer pas vous lancer des fleurs mais
vous le rôle c'est d'apaiser depuis le
début vous appeler j en veux pas du tout
à bruce toussaint
mais là c'est d'aller chercher la petite
phrase pour être celui qui aura la
petite phrase et qui fera de l'audience
et quand bfm se glorifie d'avoir fait
des records d'audience mois des records
d'audience sur des morts et sur une
révolution je suis pas sûr qu'il faille
s'en glorifier ça c'est un vrai sujet ça
mais oui c'est kelly cloud en pensée
scoop pour ça qu'il faut faire des
communiqués quand on fait des records de
danse sur ce genre de sujet là pourquoi
pas vous n'en avez pourquoi non c'est le
moteur je ne sais pas
autre nom mais je suis bien content ça
veut dire en quoi ou cheetah alors ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que le téléspectateur a
soif dans l'âme et qu'on doit lui donner
l'info ben oui non mes besoins de sang
peut-être peut-être 220 soif d'infos ne
savent pas ce qui se passe de savoir
combien de gide combien de forces de
l'ordre qui aura on apprend ce soir que
ras 90000 forces de l'ordre on veut
savoir quelle est la stratégie des
forces de l'ordre samedi
on connaissait la stratégie des forces
de notre samedi dernier et pas ce samedi
l'aja alors là n'est pas ce samedi
mais la liste qu'il y avait ce qui se
dit sur samedi il ya beaucoup de gens
disent mine de rien que vous avez les
mêmes infos que moi gilles et à
lisibilité on avait blindé qui vont
venir 65 blindés de la gendarmerie à
paris en région parisienne en renfort et
puis on dit qu'il ya des casseurs qui
ont déjà préparé des infiltrations et
que ça peut être extrêmement dangereux
et les armateurs d'extrême droite très
déterminé et d'extrême gauche il est
extra siècle oui j'ai pas une image
d'extrême gauche que d'extrême droite
malheureusement j'ai appris c'était pas
le but de ce que je voulais dire mais
vous avez raison et que du coup c'est
vrai que l'elysée a prévenu qu'ils
craignaient des morts mais c'est pour ça
que moi je suis pas dans la position
maximaliste de la violence mais vous me
dites je suis démagogues non j'essaye de
comprendre les gens quand quelqu'un de
très sensée dit je veux aller léger
c'est la manifestation d'une colère ne
les appelait jadis n'est pas terminée
j'ai pas dit jean-michel et il ne
souhaite plus si tu as tisot divine et
non à régler je serai satisfait tu sais
c'est de comprendre qu'il fasse de lui
dire tu viens de dire il y aura des
blindés des blindés c'est pas des chars
d'assaut et des véhicules de sarah des
mises au jeu indé c'est pas des chars
d'assaut est ce que j'ai dix morts
marie elodie qui censurent les choux
gras des analystes j'ai les véhicules
blindés
pensez-vous de la phrase ah bah moi je
trouve ça totalement déraisonnable ça
c'était une telle violence c'est je
trouve ça parce que criminel franchement
là aussi parce que c'est pas lui qui va
aller on auprès varie de la grappe des
fans d encadrement ils vont se laisser
porter par le vent sur la m1 tour mais
on aimait voir mais moi mais moi je suis
même peur pour ceux sur ce garçon ou
pour les autres il est jaune qu'ils
peuvent
voilà je vous le dis samedi ça peut
dégénérer on a tous
on est tous l'angoissent le samedi je
suis sûr vous nuire si vous regardez
aussi en perdre un ami dans la forme je
vais vous dire je vais te préparer
l'émission aujourd'hui chez 10 ans
laurie je verrai où que ça rigole
beaucoup d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on a
fait parce qu'on a beaucoup rigolé
depuis le début on s'est marré c'est
vrai mais c'est vrai aussi marc et moi
même me rappelle pas ce que j'ai dit
aujourd'hui je pense que les gens ils
ont une telle angoisse de ce qui va se
passer samedi qu'il faut les faire
rigoler il faut les faire marrer nous
projet vous oublie aujourd'hui un
hashtag qui est qui ressortit si le
hashtag stop violences
on vous le dit vraiment les gilet jaune
moi je vous ai toujours soutenu vraiment
stop violences y en a plein et la
majeure partie des gilet jaune à 95%
ils sont dans ce mode là ils ont ils
vont pas ils veulent pas qu'ils aient de
violence et je vous dis tout le monde se
sent paralysé samedi
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui vont
voilà qu'ils vont faire faillite à cause
aussi mais grâce à ce beau mouvement ou
à cause de ce mot enfin à cause de ce
mouvement mais parce que ce mouvement se
bat aussi pour que ça aille mieux pour
pour tout le monde mais mine de rien
aujourd'hui il ya plein de gens qui ont
raté leur saison est vraiment top
une violence samedi en art c'est
impératif obligera dit si vous permettez
syrie moi j'aimerais avoir une pensée
particulière pour les crs les policiers
les pompiers et les gendarmes
mais moi au moins j'ai une pour ses
défilés jo de nommer chêne foncé j'ai
une pensée pour évoluer chez les jaunes
qui vont y aller samedi aussi wina mais
sauf que je vous assure que après les
attentats il ya eu des marches blanches
à paris et partout en france et on
applaudissait tous les policiers et on
leur disait merci
alors soit on est ingrat sont amnésiques
et soit on est stupide et on est tous en
train d'être les uns contre les autres
et les huissiers ce n'est pas des
lentilles et surtout ils sont les rues
sinon ils sont aussi j'ai légion les
bases et c'est bien sûr que les
policiers tous besoin pour les séjours
jaune ouest jeudi gm
j'ai discuté avec avec de nombreux
policiers crs ou encore avec des filets
jaunes et que ce soit du côté des filets
jaunes qui vont y aller samedi ou du
côté des crs et des jeunes policiers qui
vont être sur le terrain samedi
ils ont tous une angoisse c'est que ça
dégénère des deux côtés on n'a pas envie
que ça dégénère
des deux côtés on est fatigué parce que
les gilet jaune ils font le mouvement
depuis des semaines et des semaines ils
sont fatigués quand on est fatigué on
peut faire n'importe quoi moi j'aurai
dans nos balances ton poste demain je
vous dis un témoignage d'un casseur un
mec qui est devenu casseurs qui était
gilet jaune
il va nous expliquer comment il a été
pris dans le mouvement 1 qu'il est
devenu resterait dans m'expliquer ça
demain soir dans l'émission mais je vous
dis et que ce soit les crs et policiers
qui ont des ordres d'un côté de l'autre
côté ils disent nous on est on est on
avec eux dans le côté ils ont des ordres
ils sont assouplies ce très jeune et ils
se disent c'est quand il ya un an quand
on voit les images qu'on a vu samedi
dernier et qu'on nous dit cette semaine
ça va être pire on se pose bien sûr des
questions et on se dit on a envie
vraiment des nappes dans l'apaisement on
a envie que ça avance moi ce que je
pense c'est que déjà ce qu'ils ont fait
les gilet jaune
ils l'ont fait pour toute la france
indoor air c'est vrai qu'ils ont fait
pour tout le monde et aujourd'hui on
voit que mine de rien ils ont réussi à
faire quand même reculer les choses je
les rats avancer les choses puisque il
ya déjà des mesures qui ont été prises
je pense qu'il faut se calmer un petit
peu essayé de repartir au dialogue
d'essayer de faire encore avancer les
choses je pense que ça va donc très bon
sens et j'ai peur que ce qui se passe
demain fasse reculer encore les choses
et que là on roi on rentre dans caceis
passé ben non ça il faut faire on rentre
dans une spirale venin passé et qui
deviennent venir dans une spirale on se
dit ça va être la spirale de l'horreur
et là on va plus pouvoir rien contrôler
la ans contrôle encore les choses ça et
encore un dialogue et là ça peut être
extrêmement grave on ne pourra plus
revenir en arrière